What we've seen so far--we've analysed a bunch of different families of graphs,
and we've found that for all these examples the number of edges is like ÃËœ(n).
It grows linearly with the number of edges.
You might wonder at this point, is that all there is in life?
Is it always the case that the number of edges grows linearly with the number of nodes.
The answer, of course, is no.
Let's consider the complete graph, also known as a clique on n-nodes.
In a complete graph, every node is connected to every other node,
and you get very pretty star patterns if you fill these in.
In this case, we have five nodes and a total of ten edges.
But this doesn't really tell us anything about the growth rate.
It just tells us that in this one example, well, it could be that the number of edges
is twice the number of nodes. We don't know.
We need to generate a more comprehensive formula.
In fact, I'm going to say you need to generate a more comprehensive formula.
In this question, I'd like you to actually work out the number of edges in a complete graph on n nodes.
The way you should submit this to us is by writing a function in Python that's called "clique"
and is given one value n, which is going to be an integer greater than 0,
and it should calculate from that the number of edges that will be created
if you fully connect all those nodes,
and then just return that answer back so that we can grade it.